Jay Bilas joining us on the program I'm
there with you Jay I understand it and I
just think common sense has to be
applied here you know we got basketball
games in 90 minutes coming up and I just
I I have to be overly cautious instead
of under cautious here and I'd rather be
told all you overreacted then we've
already under reacted how did you come
to this conclusion that maybe we should
just cancel March Madness
well it was yesterday when when the
decision came out I thought the
n-c-double-a acted appropriately and in
the first step saying that we're going
to play with no fans because the
tournament's not for another week but
what was inappropriate was the lack of
coordination with conferences that all
the conference commissioners should have
been told about that the conference's
didn't learn the power five conferences
didn't learn about the NCAA's decision
until they got an email at 4:30
yesterday afternoon so when that went
out you knew okay there are going to be
any fans today meaning you know tomorrow
meaning today and but yet the ACC in the
big 10 the big 10 was walking distance
from the n-c-double-a office and they
played with fans last night and there
was no time for any of the conference's
to pivot so there was no need for the
answer no ability to cancel the
n-c-double-a tournament because there's
still time to do that but I don't see
Dan how we can how the the institutions
the member institutions can shut their
campuses down tell their students not to
come back from Spring Break and yet play
in conference tournaments when the paid
paid professionals have said we're not
playing and then FIBA came out this
morning and said play is suspended until
June that's that's a tough look and I'm
still waiting for someone to provide a
justification for why we play and I
haven't heard one yet so for me not only
the optics but just sort of the the
public health from a public health
standpoint I don't see how it's
appropriate to play and to put these
players at risk even if they can say
that the risk is limited now that there
are no fans in the arena I just don't
see it being the right thing to do who
made this call
well each as you know each conference
makes the call individually now that
there I know that the commissioners are
now talking about this together to see
you know to share information but this
should have been coordinated on the
n-c-double-a level like this is what a
governing body is supposed to do they're
supposed to like the assembly can't just
call the ACCC and say hey play we are
suspending your play tomorrow they can't
do that
but what Mark Emmert could do is get
everybody together and say look this is
what this is what we're being told by
our public health professionals and our
the panel that we have on this this is
the decision we've come to for the
tournament and we need to coordinate so
that we all are on the same page with
how we handle this going forward so that
the conference commissioners could act
in a in concert and make the best
decision or the enterprise rather than
just an individual conference but Dan
you know listen this is not a craven
thing or anything but there's money at
issue here and money is an important
issue the n-c-double-a office for the
tournament has has insurance that can
can help make up for this if not pay for
the losses entirely because it's a multi
venue event that goes on over three
weeks so so a catastrophic event that
that impacts that they can insure
against that it is much more difficult
for a conference to insure against a
single venue event so they essentially
be paying so much for insurance they're
better off self-insuring so the
conferences are going to lose a lot of
money one by having no fans they'll lose
a lot of money but they'll really lose a
lot of money if they shut the tournament
down from here on out
but I just don't see any any other way
around it maracas my mind that we're not
for it would that we're playing today
yeah I'm just looking at the numbers
game here Jay just applying common sense
or at least trying to the rudy gobert
test positive if he doesn't test
positive last night that games played
the pelicans against Sacramento is
played but one person tested positive
and the number of people came in contact
with Rudy Gobert over the last week or
two weeks the odds would probably lead
you to believe at least one player is
gonna have the coronavirus or may test
positive for it and then all
sudden do you shut down the tournament
if it happens at that point like I and
that's maybe worst case scenario but I
think it's probably what is real in this
situation that's exactly right
that it strains the mind to think that
there is an NBA player at least one that
has tested positive for coronavirus and
that it doesn't extend further and you
could you could then have college teams
that so many more college teams and
college players from every corner of the
country that are flying all over the
place that don't have it as well that
strains the mind to think that college
players are free from the virus and
there's no risk there or an acceptable
risk when the the NBA took this took
this action I think but they were ahead
of everything they had planned this out
and and the Gobert situation was sort of
the last the last domino to fall and and
this had to be this actually had to be
taken what was interesting to me dan and
I I don't know if you'll agree with this
or not but but Mark Cuban I thought
showed not only a great tone in handling
this but but great leadership in
stepping out and saying it providing his
thoughts and and also a calming effect I
think in the handling of this and that's
what we should have at the n-c-double-a
level and we've had it at different
times at the conference levels although
I just I still don't I haven't heard the
justification for why we're playing as
opposed to why we're not but these are
difficult issues you're trying to cut
everybody as much slack as you can but I
agree with you that that sort of caution
and and being Prudential in this is the
way to go and I'm not sure we're there
yet we're about to play like I'm sitting
in the arena at the ACC tournament and
I'm not even sure how we come on the air
like I'm almost going to have to convey
hey we're flying blind just like you are
here we're going to provide you all the
information we can we're going to do the
best we can to call this game but but we
do understand that there are greater
issues here in the backdrop and and cut
us some slack too because we're doing
the best we can it's going to be really
difficult is it good
be empty it is empty there's going to be
a hundred and fifty tickets per
institution so they're family and and
it's and then they could have essential
personnel and all that the one thing
that that's a little bit interesting is
is they're allowing if if you brought
your band you can have your band here so
we're going to be listening to band
music and they're still going to play
the same music over the loudspeakers
have the same you know videos playing in
the arena I still haven't heard whether
you know what they usually do they shut
the lights out for pregame introductions
so I can't imagine what an empty arena
they're going to shut the lights out and
have spotlights they introducing the
players that that seems like a bizarre
thing to do but we'll see and whatever
it is we'll handle it it feels like it's
gonna be like a scrimmage and you're
gonna get different sound it's gonna
have that different feel and no home
court advantage for anybody I want to
bring back something that Tom Izzo said
about twenty minutes ago the Michigan
State head coach joined us and had this
to say what if the big ten ask you your
opinion what have been a couple days ago
if I was to be honest with you know
where I would have said hey let's play
the games and and now I'm looking at it
and saying you know it sure is starting
to lean towards maybe the best if things
were postponed or canceled yeah we're
putting these coaches in a delicate
situation here have any coaches been
public with you know their apprehension
about this not public no because they're
good soldiers and and trying to you know
to maintain an even strain with the with
their conference decisions but privately
I've had a couple coaches reach out to
me and they said the narrative that the
players will all of the players want to
play is not true that they're scared
they're nervous about this they're
worried about their families you know it
so the idea that that all of the players
are will just blindly compete whenever
they're told to compete is just not true
Thank You Jay we appreciate your time
I'll be watching if you want to make it
personal and you know yell hello to me
be more than happy to you know text you
back well I have a sign that says the
Dan Patrick is greater than J Phyllis
that I'm going to hold on well I hope
you'll be I don't he'll be okay with
that
how was Dayton how to date and treat you
it was awesome it was absolutely awesome
what a wonderful place as you know and
then you know you couldn't be happier
for a place like that in a program like
that to get this kind of spotlight I
they obviously deserve it but to put a
spotlight on what a great community that
is couldn't have been a better day for
us we were so honored to be there and I
love the jacket the electric jacket that
you had there yeah wasn't that was a
good look for me I think I enjoyed the
the pilot's hat frankly and I would love
to I would love to make that
announcement you know get on and tell
everybody tell everybody I'm in charge
and buckle up well you could be a flight
attendant and do that you don't have to
be the captain that well that would be
the most entertaining preflight safety
briefing you've ever hey have fun today
and thank you again for joining us Jay
thank you brother that's Jay Bilas from
the mothership